hello my trashy slugs come see me live
i'll be at the hartford funny bone
august 27th and 28th the milwaukee
improv september 3rd through 4th i'll be
[ __ ] and vomiting into a bucket
doing ayahuasca september 5th and 6th
i'll be at zany's in chicago september
7th and 8th cleveland hilarity september
9-11 never forget and i'll be at the
life is beautiful concert in vegas
september 18th and 19th go to
annieletterman.com for more tour dates
there's so many more coming up from
october on all right bye hi slugs it's
me
i just wanted to let you know i have a
website with all my tour dates you can
check them out at esther on ice.com i
don't know i'm not a figure skater but i
thought that was cute but i'm announcing
i'm coming to new york in the fall and
as you know all over florida and
san francisco and portland i'll see you
guys there get tickets at esteronice.com
and please check out the sad malibu
barbie drop for sleepover by esther at
sleepovermaster.com
by the way you said that you didn't have
a cowboy outfit i don't this was the
most cowboy outfit i've ever seen no
like hey she just threw that together i
don't know
you know woke up this morning i'm
wearing magnetic ones by the way you
look indian right now i know i know i
was like there's definitely like a cops
and robbers missing out because of
cultural appropriation and you've got to
stop this people
appropriate what's the one thing that
you wore once upon a time that you for
sure cannot bring back now i mean
jeans no i mean like for halloween when
i was younger i dressed as osama bin
laden or i dressed as pocahontas one
time i really went for the full cultural
experience
i was gonna say you know what you know
what you know what also by the way she
looks like pocahontas is dating a cowboy
and
she's wearing his stuff and then bobby
walks in you're like who is this guy he
must be
you must be bounty hunters that have
come to get this guy and get him into
jail
i'd like to consider myself a bounty
cunter in this outfit
it's pretty good
what would a cunter do explain your
outfit annie and by the way guys welcome
to the show we have a very special
cowboy theme if you can't already tell
by my fit
i just want to say guys the sheriff's in
town and the sheriff's got muffin tops
[Laughter]
and you're very proud of it i like that
i appreciate it and eric i feel like you
came a little bit underdressed but you
generally look like a cool older cowboy
anyways the mustache and everything
like you look like you live in brooklyn
honestly but i didn't trust
i didn't trust you guys you know like
when you say to somebody wear a costume
and then i show up looking like dracula
you guys are like what's wrong such a
good idea can we get it to esther
let's do that to esther yeah i didn't
trust you guys so i was like i'm not
dressing like a cowboy so we're dressing
like the ugliest thing we can possibly
be you guys don't even acknowledge it
just comes in and you go what the [ __ ]
we get prom makeup and stuff we look
gorgeous
[Music]
i know i told you that i gave up um
lashes last week yeah my mind has since
changed they're back on i got the these
are the magnetic ones and what are your
thoughts i was hour one we'll see
now what are your magnetic lashes you
know what's so funny i was like we're
going to be pointing a gun
are you black
enough
because i feel like you we talked during
the um what is it what was it called the
black lives matter protest it was a
protest and then but i was talking to
dark and i was like eric it's time you
have to tell us what your [ __ ]
ethnicity
it's time it's ethically ambiguous
people that are in hollywood don't
understand that what eric has is and
kali let's you can't shut the [ __ ] up
about what you are you should be very
quiet you know why because you could get
cast in so many things
now it's cultural appropriation if you
play a native american but you could
have been crushing it he will never say
so he can play anything i want to know
it's just a mix anyway my i have family
from the caribbean you know that's the
that's to say 30 40 percent black part
is my family that's from jamaica and
from belize cool and then like you know
the other side i i don't even really
know is what they're doing do you know
where in belize
what do you mean where was it in punta
gorda
oh jesus that's like but that's like the
fancy white party i'm not the poo i'm at
the punta gorda in my life right now
wait is that
well played
and it looks good we're surprised
everyone's surprised how good this
weight game looks on me i really think
everyone is
wait annie a lot of black guys i'm sure
like is that where you were you handled
or you jerked off turtles i didn't jerk
off the turtles in that one and i never
[ __ ] touched those turtles i the
[ __ ] juice was everywhere but um
i did start looking at turtles again
with love ugh what i'm changing how long
did it take
i was just at the pet store and i was
looking at them walking around their
little
the red eared
guns the whole episode yes i am
they're very light
wait i have something it's very elegant
i'll hold this instead you can pick
okay get get the gun get the gun to get
the guns just put don't even pull the
nut like please don't cut yourself
because it's time to watch it it's not a
um oh it's not a yeah it's a comb
delay
you know me enough to know that this is
a comb all right for my moustache
um
no i was in i it was the same trip i i
okay so i went i had a year off from
school this is very white girl but i had
a year off from school in between and so
i went to find yourself
yeah i find myself a i should have gone
to india found myself a sherpa dick
that's what george did he found a sherpa
dick well you were religious so you was
that your rump shrimer no i went after
uh after college i went to india to work
in bollywood
you did why does that actually look like
it's supposed to hold balls your mess
doesn't it
am i wrong gabby
i'm not trying to make a banana hammock
you give oh my god it's a banana break
hammock we should sell those merch ideas
no you should sell masks that could also
look like panties
you know what they have you know what i
mean they i was trying to get it for the
show but it was just some points or
someone sent it to me on dms but some
porn star was wearing this like mask the
suction mask over a mouth that was a set
of balls and when you breathe in and out
like the balls wiggle i wanted to get it
for the show but i i don't know if they
exist
but you got them custom made
you can make math easies because you
know but they were like these were like
there was a mold for them oh god you got
you guys like maybe i think maybe some
real balls were dipped into some is that
the thing that women buy
no you got you you know there's some
male porn star you like and you buy his
dick
you know what's his name what's his name
um there is a porn star not too far off
from what you're saying um he's a
spanish porn star and he's actually
going to prison because he
accidentally killed someone with toad
venom
um oh doing that in the compost
ceremonies yeah because it's apparently
it it mimics sort of the effects of dmt
and um nacho vidal his name is natural
you guys know nacho vidal oh no you're
going to hold up pull up that [ __ ]
let's see that dude famous
um i don't know i the only porn star's
and then once i started canceling porn
stars i was like i'm out i don't when
did they cancel porn stars they started
canceling yeah
it's a thin line between what's your job
[Laughter]
and so what was it george like he
accidentally killed someone he turned
into a shaman
with with he's a [ __ ] shaman i mean if
there's any if there's any biopic to be
made it's of this guy and what a demise
i always think about that like if you're
a shaman like i know shaman
men who are married
and it's like how do you like how do you
make the move isn't that kind of a
breach of power that's true well that's
like all those yogi guys like anybody
that's running a yoga thing yeah they're
always [ __ ] everybody at the thing
well have you seen the documentary
that's why they don't call it bikram
anymore but i mean the ones that but i
mean the ones that are like actually
like in love like even if it's like
totally innocent like that's got to be
an awkward like is this a date or are we
on
um well that's just like hallucinogens
people fall in love with their therapist
but that's illegal i know that's what
i'm saying though it shouldn't be but we
should be well i guess you just can't
shaman your girl
you got to be like
shaman hands off you got to be like my
six hands are off well it's the same way
that actually if you are let's say a
gynecologist or an obstetrician you're
not supposed to deliver your own
baby
in the hospital aren't you like i'm good
at this yeah but when your emotions are
involved you're not doing your job in
the most optimal way yeah but when
should we kind of pissed if your
boyfriend like what if bobby was a
shaman and he's like i'm sorry i i just
can't help you
what would bobby be i need you but you
but you see him helping everyone else
you'd be like yo
can i get a little
commenting i would not want any
shamaning from that man even if he was
the best shaman on earth what would he
be even a shaman of i don't [ __ ] know
like if you keep through life rolling
through life just rolling he's always
just rolling
he already is sort of a shaman of of
like the tiger belly you know people but
he thinks he is yeah oh he's like i just
said he's the david duke of there he is
a david dude of sorts i think
can i just say you look so hot this is
crazy
i do yes
i'm sad i missed the
fake modesty over there
i have low self-esteem and he knows me
she has low self-esteem it's it is
starting to get frustrating i'm going to
start slapping you around wait hang on
do you guys want to whip your ass until
you're ready it makes sense she you know
if she had better self-esteem she would
be with a hotter dude yeah well how do
you feel about your model fiancee by the
way congratulations yeah well i mean
it's all about i think women know y'all
know how to
look at other things yeah you know what
i mean this was the fake fight we got in
i'm so sorry about that can i apologize
dears later okay here we go i want to
make a puzzle apology no no it was fine
when we had the fight i thought we
squashed it until i'm looking at this
clip that people sent me from their
[ __ ] pockets
well you guys are just first of all
heard just going like can i tell you
something eric griffin said to me
like like just like just out of nowhere
i said you know what you should wear
lingerie that's not what the [ __ ]
happened and what did i do on monday i
understand but we're
so funny it live help all and then she
says and then this one jumps in oh well
let me tell you and then you even said
this i don't even remember what it was
about and then you just you know i was
like
thank god esther was just like just
gonna be quiet
[Laughter]
let's just say esther doesn't dip her
toe in the pool okay
yeah she didn't even want to show up
swim let's just say that i wanted you
guys i wanted to show you not only do i
have yeah you want to say consent
consent hit their pasties
they look great you're so lucky that
could really have been a mangled mess
because she knew she had boob jobs then
she got rid of the boobs he knows he was
there the day after i took my titties
out i was trying to look i'm trying to
see it no i mean i get it you're like no
medically i would like to say i'm
curious
but it's like it's like you know
look as a dude we have such a stupid
perspective on breast surgery you know
and i it changed i talking to a friend
of mine one time she rocked my world
with how she said it because it's like
you know uh she got a she had big
titties that were fake you know and she
said i got rid of them because i was
just tired of the attention now a guy
perspective means what do you mean
you're tired of the attention that's why
you got him you want to have big you
know and then she said to me she was
like no i just wanted to i wanted to
feel like a woman i wanted to wear
dresses a certain way i wanted to you
know i just you know you know and i was
like
oh they do look so good in shirts like i
do love a couple people on me
they did it on me it made me look like
what just turned you into a different
thing and if you have the self-esteem
you have right
it doesn't you're you're good you've
worked on it though so it's like you can
take a compliment but people that have
like true low self-esteem when someone
calls them hot it like almost hurts them
because it's like that's not how i feel
yeah i think that's mostly what you
nailed you actually nailed it right
there we all feel that i feel great you
guys can compliment me all you want i
know i'm amazing it's it took a while to
get here but
brother hansen's taking over
oh i just watched an old concert of the
hanson or the hanson brothers hanson
just hansen and oh my god annie
identical i know i'm not kidding like
people i think people think it's like a
hacky thing to say that look like i was
in middle school when they do you
remember um
yeah i looked i looked exactly the
original like they they they're they
they broke the mold of the boy band
because they actually wrote and played
their own issues i know they were like
little christian boys they were like the
georges wait but they
they now play with like the philharmonic
like they're like legitimate musicians
they also got married when they're about
13. they all have like 27 kids i was
like okay boys
they didn't succumb to the lifestyle
good for them and you know what they
also did when they were rollerblades
they wore their knee pads and their
helmets like how funny is it to be a boy
band that's all brothers that look like
girls and to wear all of your protection
in the video it's so funny what i wanted
to show you guys was actually not my
titty a very iconic shirt that i've had
for a long long time and it's a vintage
loretta lynn and conway twitty shirt oh
it's time it's a tv shirt
twitty because we did tweak those
titties did we not you could stay
that could be your merch conway titty
what did you think what do you think
what was your expectation of when i told
you like i got my implants removed what
did you think they were going to i
thought they were going to be like empty
bags like
like a bean bag that needs a refilling
and they just look like they look great
yeah that's what i thought i thought to
myself was like you know you you were
just like this busty you know what i
mean yeah i remember first meeting her
and bobby brought you around i was like
we were all pretty surprised yeah it was
all brother and then she was very like
also overly sexual you know what i mean
yeah
you know the tapes you would do what i
said i take back my apologies you would
hug me no no you would the way you would
hug people like
like i remember you gave me a hug one
time and it was like he's full of bodies
when you have double d's you don't have
a choice
also by the way i give the best [ __ ]
hugs
no that this is what you're talking
about i'm down 40 pounds you actually
don't have titties you don't have
titties you have a belly still yeah yeah
yeah it's looking better by the way this
is the hardest part to lose when you're
losing weight you lose weight like this
so i'm straight so i'm shaped like an
ostrich you know what i mean
i like an ostrich that's an ostrich
so like that's what happens the hardest
part that's the part that goes so when
i'm losing weight it always starts in my
face yeah you know what i mean and then
like it starts to go here you are like a
cute bird they're my legs yeah then it's
like right here it's where i have like a
yeah it's the hardest part but i think
that's what happens especially when you
get older like the fat loss sort of
switches and he's right it does stay in
the center
i want to go
coolsculpting and see if that works
let's just
guys
when i get a flat tire i gotta spare all
right i know
um
annie i want i will here
something happened to me this morning
feels like a bad radio show
and he said a joke
something happened to me this morning
that i desperately need your advice on
um i got a phone call from a very sad
nine-month pregnant
wife of a friend of mine
basically saying like
what is he up to
you saw him this weekend what was his
behavior like and i didn't number one i
didn't know that she was nine months
pregnant and about to pop is she fat
no
what do you mean you didn't know you
haven't well no that's how little he
when i asked him how's your wife he was
like she's just a possessive [ __ ] oh
got it and i'm like he's always trying
to get me to like put a crib together
and paint a wall blue so he's a mod so
he's a monster yeah well okay here's
just that story already lets me know
you're my friend annie this is something
you would have done because it's like
we're very tied into our friendships
that we made in high school he was a
friend a boy that i knew in high school
and i did i hadn't seen him some
questions before he finished his story
never hooked up with him okay that's the
first question bro he was did you give
him actual full
it was like one of those it was one of
those where i was like oh this is too
much no they want that it's projection
it's projection i'm going to leave it at
that
i almost kicked her in the face
mom's a face not the face please not
just the tits grow
okay so you never did wait wait yeah was
that by your choice or you both had
wasn't mutual or was he always trying to
get with you and you were one of those
like oh you're just my friend did he
want you i when i was younger i never
perceived it like that it was always a
bro sister thing i was going through a
lot and he was just a nice boy
okay and so 20 like about a month ago he
was like hey i'm going to be in la
remember danny danny used to be our old
drug dealer well just marijuana but and
and he's like let's all get together i
haven't been down in la i haven't seen
you in 20 years so i was like yeah sure
and on the night out on saturday i
invited gilbert i invited bobby neither
of them wanted to [ __ ] meet me there
because i always like protection i never
want to see someone after 20 years i
don't know what they're about they need
friends right by the way by the way you
were not invited
right now if i hadn't seen you in 20
years yeah and i walked in and you
looked like that i didn't look like this
no no i'm just saying just the way you
look in general but i'm just saying the
way you look in general i'm just saying
he was probably blown away well i was
not dressed like a hot girl i made sure
to not dress like a hot girl because i
was alone
and in downtown la's i'm like i'm not
going to play that game did you wear
your bathing cap from the last episode
with my goggles
i mean wow
just stamina don't want to [ __ ] me
criminals like don't do all that
wait does gabby do the thumbnails you
[ __ ] you're sabotaging us how good was
that though i looked like a straight up
condom head i yeah i was really proud of
you i was impressed thank you well that
was my whole life there's i can't escape
the fact that that's what swimmer is
like no i gotta i have a bathing cap i'm
sure i got one online you can find me
yeah swim caps
we were swimming we did we had an
olympic episode aren't you happy when i
was uh whatever age i was i stopped
because i didn't want to shave my body
we want you to actually we would like
you to join the swim team because that's
a lot it is what it is but you could
potentially take eight seconds off your
best time that's what i'm saying yeah it
was ridiculous that's what they were
saying to me yeah you you're good
swimmer but you need to i was like nah i
don't love this that much i love i
wanted to win so bad i shaved my [ __ ]
like that's eye shape everything so i
shaved my toe hairs what was going on in
your [ __ ] that it was that taking off
oh that's at least three seconds
[Laughter]
cbd isn't about what you feel it's about
what you don't feel stress anxiety pain
feels is a premium cbd that will help to
keep your head clear and feel your best
it's hassle-free delivered directly to
your door cbd naturally helps reduce
stress anxiety pain and big thing for us
sleeplessness but seriously i mean i'm
like
for real this is for frills feels it
this is the cbd there's a million cbd's
out there but i'm telling you like i
need a little edge when i come to this
podcast if i take it before it's not a
good i'm telling you like
it's so relaxing there's no hangover or
addiction place a few drops of fields
under your tongue and feel the
difference within minutes the thing to
remember about cbd is that finding your
right those is important and everyone's
dose is different in fact feels offers a
free cbd hotline that will help guide
your personal experience so you can find
the perfect dose the feels customer
service team is dedicated to making sure
you get the best use of your cbd start
feeling better with feels become a
member today by going to feels.com
tuesday and you'll get 50 off your first
order with free shipping that's f e a l
s dot com slash tuesday to become a
member and get 50 automatically taken
off your first order with free shipping
fields.com tuesday you guys these big
wireless providers
there's always a catch so when we first
heard about mint mobile and how they
offer premium wireless service starting
at just 15 bucks a month we thought
what's the catch but after speaking with
them and using their service it all made
sense there isn't one mint mobile secret
sauce is that they're the first company
to sell wireless service online only by
cutting out retail stores there's no
crazy overhead cost they get passed down
to you in any form no mystery fees
instead mint just passes on sweet
savings direct to you i finally got to
get off my dad's family plan
for people looking for extra savings
mint mobile offers premium wireless for
just listen to this 15 bucks a month
dollars do you know how much i used to
freaking pay
on my just on my solo data plan alone
148 dollars
not anymore not worth it all plans with
mint mobile come with unlimited talk and
text plus high-speed data delivered on
the nation's largest 5g network use your
own phone with any mint mobile plan and
keep your same phone number along with
all of your existing contacts if you're
not 100 satisfied mint mobile has you
covered with their 7-day money-back
guarantee switch to mint mobile and get
premium wireless service starting at
just fifteen dollars a month that's just
fifteen dollars a month yeah what are
you spending fifteen dollars on
everything two coffees it's nothing to
get your new wireless plan for just
fifteen dollars a month and get the plan
shipped to your door for free go to mint
mobile.com
tuesday that's mint mobile.com
tuesday cut your wireless bill to 15
bucks a month at mint mobile.com
tuesday
that was a visual right there okay so
you walk into the restaurant we call it
a tuft i like your house
um so anyways
he's a sexist here we go
remember when i go your arms offensive
anti i go i go your arms it is what it
is but your ass hair is disgusting yeah
no the way she said it was disgusting
you guys will just [ __ ] listen to my
story you're the one that went on a
[ __ ] tangent about your hairy ass we
always let you finish your stories on
this podcast
of hair oh you want to make it a tuft
okay just for the imagery anyways so i
did go out i hung out with this person
and my ex drug dealer for an hour of my
life and it was a good time but who i
saw was not the same person i knew 20
years ago this person was looking to
party and looking a [ __ ] and looking to
misbehave and i and all i know is that
he is married he has a kid and that's i
asked him so he always wanted you
yeah i'm sure he did okay well i'm glad
i rolled up looking like a [ __ ] dude
is what i'm saying well and so uh when i
saw his behavior i asked him i was like
wait like you know what is it like how's
your wife how's your family and
basically it's like oh she's possessive
and i was like no she's not possessive
if she knew how you were behaving
like based on what i'm seeing i was like
she's not possessive she's correct yeah
she's her intuition is driving her
[ __ ] crazy well i got a message this
morning
a long essay
and it's his wife she's nine months
pregnant and she basically said i saw
the messages he was sending you on
facebook he's like she was like you were
super appropriate
and um but i want to know like you know
he's like i'm desperate i've been with
him for 15 years like i'm about to pop
like something has changed in him in the
last three months
and i didn't know what to say so i said
hey call me i don't want to have to
explain myself on text
and i was like i think that you should
deny it to him i didn't say anything
what are you talking about that's where
her mind goes see what i mean it's like
a tricky [ __ ] over here no i don't try
account and i i didn't i felt so bad she
was crying and i was like look like
trust your intuition i was like i
haven't seen him in 20 years i don't
know what his baseline behavior was but
he's not the person i knew right 20
years ago and i was like you're nine
months pregnant if you're about to pop
tomorrow like he should have been with
you not to insert myself here but like
homegirl like trust yourself is
basically what i told her and now i feel
guilty that i said that no you have to
because she asked you it's like you have
to tell the truth i do right yeah of
course well it's not even just that you
it's okay for you to feel empathy and
put yourself in the situation if you if
you're in a similar situation you're
saying i would feel that way too and
you're you know what i mean like it's
yeah it's not your job what are you
supposed to do
it's not your job to control her like
having positive emotions it's your job
to answer her well should i answer it at
all or she just stayed out of it
i just asked you though she asked you
it's like i don't know yeah and i was
like i'm a girl's girl like if i were in
her shoes i just put myself in here you
like could have ghosted but it's like
why
yeah that would have made it i think i
think that you would you would be
sitting here going
it would have been a different question
you had been asking us should i have
said something that's what you would be
doing right now if you didn't so either
way you followed your instinct and you
did what you needed to do i think you
god if someone i'm i just try to be
honest and it's like he's doing the
thing it's like i do that too where i'm
like i'm always like protecting
someone's bad behavior i'm like why am i
protecting you yes and
so that's what i thought in the past
because you know i've always been
friends with dudes yes that's always
happened and it's like wait a second
like why am i being such a [ __ ] pikmi
girl and like defending these dudes bad
behavior
when and i know they're my friends but
at the same time it's like i had a
when i was in my most heightened
triggered like
like accepting my trauma that it
happened to me i mean i was [ __ ]
livid it was like
i don't know five years ago or something
i mean i was just like so i had just
realized that everything that happened
to me did not happen to everyone yeah
and that like it wasn't my fault and i
was just like everyone like just so
upset i went on a podcast and i said how
i don't want dick pics i was like i do
not like dick pics and some guy sent me
a dick pic right after that i took a
screenshot of it and i posted it onto
his facebook page and he freaked out and
started calling i don't know how he had
kurt's number but he had kurt metzger's
numbers on his podcast
and so he freaked out he's like i'm a
teacher like she used to take it
downward i'm like no no you sent the
thing i said i don't want something like
the insult happened when you sent the
thing yeah whatever happens after that
is not my [ __ ] problem it's like my
choice to do with that information what
i want to do yeah and i think what
ultimately how i feel about this whole
thing is exactly that where it's like if
you were to call me and say hey why the
[ __ ] would you even like open your mouth
i'm like dude like i don't have i i'm
just knowing you again i just met you
for an hour i didn't know that you had a
nine and a half month [ __ ] pregnant
wife at home had i known that in a piece
of information i wouldn't have gone out
with it i wouldn't at all oh yeah like
why are you here yeah like why are you
here getting
like absolutely demolished and then
showing me pics of like women you've
hooked up with i'm like i
i wouldn't and anyways it was just
really sad and like ooh well that that
so now it's like did you tell her that
part no well you just did well show
watchers
i basically said like i was like he
looks like a guy like spiraling in some
way
and i was like that's that's really all
like i can say like that was my
perception of everything
they obviously going through something
oh i just felt like the heartache in her
voice and i just felt like really sick
about it this morning well i met a guy
once who was like
at a wedding and he was trying to say he
was in an open marriage and i was like i
was like not i was like not having it
anyway you know but he was like yeah i'm
in an open marriage i was like does she
know like i [ __ ] hate that [ __ ] like
yeah you're an open marriage but he had
all these kids and stuff and um
he was saying to me like he's like yeah
we just don't have sex or whatever and i
was trying to be like all right i'll
listen to this guy i'll be like a woman
that's not his wife i'll hear him out
not interested in [ __ ] him at all but
um he was like he's like yeah and it's
just like we never have sex anymore and
i was like oh well why don't you like
try to like
do stuff for her so she wants to he goes
no it's i don't want to [ __ ] her and i
was like oh
i was like oh i'm so over this i don't
feel bad for you and he's like yeah it's
just after she had the kids and i know
that's like a real thing that happens to
guys where but [ __ ] you that's your
problem that's not the girl oh my god
that's exactly what the his wife said to
me this morning she's like you know i'm
on my second kid my body has changed my
self-esteem is really low she's like i
just want to know the truth
and i'm like oh can i can i ask you a
question yeah
is your response always here comes a guy
in whatever setting
and he's clearly
trying to get with you
you entertain this or is there ever
anything in you just to be like
this is not gonna happen
yeah but i'm saying like what um do you
ever do that or if you don't why not
sometimes i do and sometimes i don't
right so sometimes it's like
it's like it depends on what the
situation is like if it's someone who is
like i'm working with you kind of have
to like there's a dance you have to do i
mean it's like guys are always doing
some [ __ ] but it's like i
you ha it's just like you just
be gross she's she's right there's
always a dance because it's like i'm not
gonna [ __ ] me too i'm not gonna be
like this guy is attracted to me or
whatever it's like he's just like
shooting a shot i let people shoot their
shot once same if they do it again i i'm
like and i've already said no that's
like that's a [ __ ] that's a problem
and he's 1000 correct it's like
i'm not supposed to assume that he knows
i have a boyfriend he's shooting a shot
right so in that moment i'm polite and i
i take on like whatever advances he's
putting on because i don't he doesn't
know
but in that moment where he's like
asking for my number and i'm just like
hey like no thanks like you know i'm not
interested i don't even say i have a
boyfriend actually i'm not interested
yeah only because it's like i'm not
saying no because i have a boyfriend i'm
saying no because it's no well there's
like back in the day
that's a whole different thing because
that makes him feel like if the
boyfriend was out exactly right right
yeah and then sometimes it's like
sometimes you're like maybe i do want to
just give this guy the ego thing and
it's like sorry i'm just like not
available now or whatever you know just
like let them feel fine and then they go
off sometimes yeah and that's like who
knows that's like from whatever my own
[ __ ] is from yeah with my dad my
brothers and guys i dated when i was a
kid well it's it's
even in that moment there like when i
was younger i used to feel codependent
where i'm like i don't want anyone to
walk away feeling bad yeah but like as
i've gotten a little bit like where i am
now i'm just like i'm just too tired to
take care of anyone's feelings anymore
it's better for them too right to know
like to know the truth i mean you should
know what your batting average is you
should write the truth about it
surprisingly i would always prefer i
prefer somebody just being like no thank
you yeah and i'm just like okay cool
boom done well you know what a lot of
guys actually take it pretty well
exactly like huh they take it pretty
well
that's why i'm trying to that's what i'm
trying to say i think that like
i feel like
you're gonna get the visceral response
that you probably need anyway like it's
all i'm saying like if you go no
then and if the guy's like well [ __ ] you
then it's like well i'll say this is
what i'm saying no yeah i just go or a
guy's gonna be like i had a guy so i had
a producer guys
this project i was working on and i
would get like i was going in like not
every time yeah like so i wasn't like a
regular writer on the show
and he [ __ ] leaned in focus and i was
so pissed and i immediately like i was
like no dude so annoyed it's just so
annoying it's like you're in like
you are the one that hires me like [ __ ]
you and so i was so annoyed because and
i used to have so much fun with him i
just like hang out with him all the time
and i was like are you serious dude and
then the minute i was single he did that
and then i was like all right shoot your
shot whatever maybe you just like me
and then maybe he obviously liked you
yeah yeah i know it's not always like
but it's just so [ __ ] so annoying
it's like can we do it when the [ __ ]
show's over but um and also can we not
do it i didn't want to do it anyway but
so i was like like no and then i left
and then i texted him i was like so when
am i coming in the room again like
immediately like
i'm not like forfeiting my [ __ ] job
you know like i'm just like hey remember
we work together and yeah
the other end of that though is there
are moments that annie and i talk about
where it's like it's very clear
someone's coming on to you and you say
no but when i have a girls night out
the rules change a little bit and the
rules change on the dance floor so i
always tell bobby this i call it my it's
called hf which is
heavy flirting but i take no numbers i
take no names i don't even look at their
[ __ ] face hoe form
i thought it was heavy flow oh my gosh
she's bleeding on them that's great and
so let's say for instance i'm dancing
there's someone behind me and i'm just
dancing i will i will grind up on
whatever dick there is behind me not
even turn around to look at their face
the song is over i walk straight forward
there's no exchange of words there's no
exchange of anything it's just
having a good time which is going on how
many guys leaving uh how many guys right
now watching this or like
hoping they see her at a at a dance club
like i'd love to get those kalila blue
balls yeah she's like there's
they got sweat pants on with no
underwear
i imagine i'm imagining her doing it but
it's square dance
like i don't get to touch their dicks
and square dance collisions or it's a
wedding thing got to the left
thank god to the right it's a [ __ ] um
cha cha electric the electric slide but
bobby is so not threatened um by
anything
at all like even when i said i was like
sweetie please come with me to see an
old friend of mine he's like please
please please don't make me go please
don't make me go and i was like what if
like he's into me he's like i don't give
a [ __ ] please don't make me go yeah
i totally get that energy i don't want
to go see you some guy from high school
just gets so sad yeah it's like why you
don't want to see that the life leave
the eyes of a man when you show up with
a guy
you know what it is though you know what
we need to work on because i'm actually
getting a lot like these questions
you're asking are interesting because i
think i've done so much work on myself
just in the past like few years that i
would have a completely different
situation well you know what i want to
say about what you were saying earlier
is and what i appreciate about you in
this moment is
especially because
this is layered it's nuanced because
like it's you having a good time with
the guy you work with there is some
chemistry because you're having a good
time all right so
is there a possibility like and it's
like what you're talking about is hey
let's be professional so yeah we're
having this thing let's be professional
so maybe like outside of work if you
want to take a shot cool
if i and if i want to say at that point
hey listen i really enjoy working with
you but i don't want to i'm not romantic
with you like that
is there and then it's like on the other
person to be like all right you know
what yeah i'm into you like that but i
think we have a good one like if he
stopped bringing me in that's a fun
that's [ __ ] exactly that's amazing
that's right but the thing also is it's
like okay so louie and his apology said
this and i thought this was actually so
good in his apology he said when i was
asking these girls what i thought i was
doing was asking these girls a question
but what i realized now is i was
presenting them with a predicament and
that's something that i was like oh that
kind of like felt like rung true where i
was like in these working environments
when you are kind of afraid of that and
it's like it is a comedy room so it's
like and we you're right we do have
chemistry but i'm like dude i'm [ __ ]
crushing in this room right now like do
not ruin this thing
because you want to get your dick wet
it's like it's not like he was on one
knee proposing to me it's like he was
trying to [ __ ] me at a party you know
what i mean yeah yeah yeah dude like but
i had to and my ex-boyfriend helped me
with this um because i used to get so
offended when when guys hit on me i went
i thought it meant they didn't think i
was funny
right like i thought it was like you
know all of these like the [ __ ] guys
tell you when you're coming up and
you're doing well they're like it's just
cause you're a girl i'm like i'm [ __ ]
funnier than you dude like i'm sorry i
was funnier than these [ __ ] guys but
then it gets in your head eventually you
go wait am i only getting things because
everyone's trying to [ __ ] me you know
and then so i had this thing in my head
where i felt like when guys hit on me it
meant they didn't think i was funny or
respect me and what i realized is that's
not i mean that's just like from my own
past [ __ ] with i get it molested um but
it's like
what i what he taught me was he's like
no they could be they're probably just
more attracted to you because they think
you're funny so it's not like so there
is a way to make it there is a way to be
like oh i'm going to take the compliment
of this and just like tell them the
truth and not worry about their feelings
but just like tell them the truth rather
than
trying to like maneuver around it but
see i feel like it should be dealt with
i mean i feel like people should have
more open communication about this i
think instead of like denying like i
never was like when i was younger i'd be
the kind of person i'd be like i'd be
like that guy
pretending like i'm your friend and then
a year later i'm like i love you i've
always loved you and it's so [ __ ]
annoying right i know how annoying that
is right so later when i got later when
i was like had more confidence in myself
i would be like nah nah nah no i'm not
trying to be your friend right yeah
listen i don't let people dictate the
terms of the relationship to me right i
don't get friend zoned because i'm like
nah yeah i'm trying to get with you
you're getting way blacker no i'm just
saying
when i hear guys talk about like she's
got me in the friend zone no no you
staying in the friend zone it is totally
okay to tell somebody
no because first of all you know what it
is you can't just be my friend
do you know how how
how what it means to build a friendship
you can't just tell me oh we're friends
now no i don't know you like that you
know so no we're trying to i'm trying to
get with you so you deal with that yeah
you have to put it and then if you go
and then so if you say well let's i
don't want to do that the other person
has to have some maturity to be like you
know what this chick's talented i like
how we work together i like what she
does i'll just i just have to deal with
my attraction but i don't say you deny
it yeah the dude's into you because you
were great yeah you know you were funny
and you were attractive and you guys had
good chemistry he just needs to learn
how to deal with working with somebody
you feel that way about it it's just
like it does feel like such a like a
weird betrayal that when you're like not
expecting it it's the same as the friend
thing like it's like so you've been
friends with this long or we've been
working like it's just like that's what
your intentions were
this whole time it's like oh it's so
annoying
but i'm saying to to go in on that
before i don't want to cut you off but i
just want to because this is great you
can cut me off no no it's just i don't
so it's just that
annie
we both know we're both carrying a
credit balance month after month listen
i got a back pain carrying uh
this debt around all right
if you dread looking at your credit card
statements like i do you're not alone
that can feel
absolutely crippling in fact we should
do that as a segment i would love to
read your credit card statements you
would go crazy mine would be a lot of
crab legs
upstart has been a godsend upstart can
help you on your path to financial
freedom upstart is the fast and easy way
to pay off your debt with a personal
loan all online whether it's paying off
credit cards consolidating high interest
debt or funding personal expenses over
half a million people have used upstart
to get one fixed monthly payment unlike
other lenders upstart considers your
income and current employment to find
you a smarter rate for your loan
uh where it was upstart when i needed it
ten years ago
with a fire was it ten days oh wait i
haven't
with a five-minute online rate check you
can see your rate up front for loans
between one thousand to fifty thousand
dollars you can receive funds as fast as
one business day after accepting your
loan find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com tuesday that's upstart.com
tuesday don't forget to use our url to
let them know we sent you loan amounts
will be determined based on your credit
income and certain other information
provided in your loan application go to
upstart.com
tuesday if you're anything like me
shopping for new clothes can be
needlessly stressful it's so honestly
it's so annoying i don't want to wait in
lines we listen if our pandemic told us
anything we don't have to go outside
anymore okay we don't certainly not for
close i'm not waiting in line for
clothes so why not let stitch fix make
it easy by doing the work for you and
you can spend time doing the things you
actually love instead [ __ ] fix offers
clothing hand selected by expert
stylists for your unique size style and
budget it's a completely different and
fun way to find clothes that you like
hold on it's a completely different and
fun way to find clothes that you will
love to wear every piece is chosen just
for you every piece is chosen for your
fit in your life and it's the easy
solution to finding what makes you look
and feel your best and try on pieces at
home before you buy keep what you love
and return what you don't stitch fix has
free shipping easy returns and exchanges
and a prepaid return envelope is
included because let's be real if it's
not nothing's getting returned
on top of that my favorite part is
there's no subscription required you can
try stitch fix just once
or set up automatic deliveries you'll
pay just 20 styling fee for each box
which gets credited towards pieces you
keep and there are no hidden fees ever
get started today at stitchfix.com
tuesday and you'll get 25 off when you
keep everything in your fix that's
stitchfix.com
tuesday for 25 off when you keep
everything in your fix
stitchfix.com
tuesday
it's like
that i don't think that should be what
you think but i understand why you think
that way and that's what i'm saying on
the other side guys
you know
deal with your feelings so it's like
it's like no no that's not the reason
because it's like i can understand i got
if i'm in that situation i'm just saying
well damn this is this is like why not
and my my response to that is always
just because you can
doesn't mean you should
but don't ignore the fact that you want
it right just deal with those feelings
that's the most important thing
is to like not be threatened by your
attraction towards other people because
what happens is that people think they
always have to act on their feelings and
sometimes
sometimes you just gotta feel it without
opening your [ __ ] mouth and i always
tell bobby this like or legs ladies or
legs
but it's like that's the hard part it's
like do you do i believe that bobby has
only ever had feelings for me in the
eight years i've been with him unlikely
does he believe
that i've only had like attraction for
him of course not but it's like i'm not
threatened by
either i like how i was like
not likely and then hers is of course
not
but
you see that distinction there
but it's like
if i
if i'm just not threatened by it because
i'm a [ __ ] human being and it's
always going to exist i just don't act
on it because i'm mature enough
yeah yeah i have like i've had guys that
like before i was dating todd we were
like so [ __ ] flirty like it was like
i'm like twirling my hair and spinning
around them and now when i see them it's
like hey sir
you know like it's like i just won't
like i just it's just that's not like
what is in this world for me anymore you
guys remember that show uh my so-called
life yes
second season you can still do it i know
my so-called life is literally a perfect
show it was a perfect
so she had sex with her boyfriend okay
right and the football player the
football and then she said something
that was so it was so great because she
was saying like once you let a guy have
sex with you he then
thinks that he can have it all the time
i was just talking about this with my
hypnotist you know what i mean
so uh and i th and this is what we're
talking about right now it's just a
perspective you need to have just you
know so it's like for like that's a guy
thing it's like hey
we we [ __ ] yeah so now we [ __ ] now
i used to have a joke about when i was
like when i was uh first doing comedy i
was like you know twice i was like i'm
not ready i'm 27 and i'm not ready
because you do it's almost like you it's
like [ __ ] you just don't once you [ __ ]
them it's like yeah you have this like
responsibility responsibility
when you're saying as a female
perspective you feel like well now
and i and i'm saying again
we really got to get to a point of
communication where it's just like just
because i i did this but i don't want to
do it again or i don't want to do it all
the time or hey just because i maybe i
had a weak moment moving forward though
i would like it to be more romantic now
or whatever it is like that i mean
that's just what happens
can i raise my gun real quick go ahead
how much better would our show have been
that pilot if we could have had real
perspectives i know but the thing is is
like the guy that was making it he just
wasn't
like it was like they they tried to like
match something together and i knew the
potential i said the potential could
have been like it would be a great
[ __ ] [ __ ] i'm saying this is it guys
if you want to show about two uber
drivers that are actually comedians that
are driving people to go meet up with
their what was it like they were like we
were like gonna bring people back
together no it was just about like i
don't even at this point now it's so
muddled in my head that i'm just like
whatever what but it was guys and girls
you know you know different perspectives
dealing with like and it just it just
didn't go the way we wanted it to go
clearly
to hell you know but it was just the
potential was there i mean i thought we
were right we had good whatever
but that show i'm just saying like
that's just by the way
most romantic moment in tv history to me
was when they're walking down the
hallway and she you know he wasn't
acknowledging that uh-huh they were
together they were dating and then uh
you know oh and they hold a hand and
then she has that look on her face
when he did the lean i'm telling you do
you know how many guys i wasn't
attracted to got me sopping wet because
they did the jordan catalano lean it's
like this is what you have to do you
have to lean in
don't this is actually me too now but if
a girl is like against a wall and they
the guy would lean in he would just like
he would take your personal space from
you a little bit and then not say
something hot like just say something
like
do you like pickles or what i mean that
actually sounds like a sexual thing but
like you know like do you want a
sandwich like it was just like yes the
lean
oh my god some girl by the way came to
my show in buffalo and her name is
jordan catalano oh my god i feel like
i've missed out on an entire you can
still watch this i'm going to watch this
listen there's every character in this
show is somebody that you know it never
made it to the philippines how what it
could oh man this was such a great what
we'll try to get you really should and
esther's never seen any tv show except
the twilight zone too sure and uh what
oh we shouldn't watch tv we should do a
episode by episode recap yes
it's so it's literally my dream zoom me
in for that cause
i love that show i say this all the time
if i think my life would be completely
different if there was a second season
of that show oh
wait there was there only one yes yes it
was a nightmare what happened you look
at you read like listen you're going to
watch that show and you're going to be
like i need to know what happens to
these people but why was there only one
season i read a book that was like the
woman wrote a book i read a book that
was like supposed to be the second but
there was like it was like a whole lot
of things contracts it was like at that
particular time too shows they need to
get like 20 you know 20 million views to
be like you know that show now would be
the best show on tv
i remember hearing too that it was
actually
targeted towards parents it was supposed
to be like more about like the parents
and how they deal oh i was so were you
upset when the mom cut her hair i was
yeah it was triggering because my mom
went that route too but it dealt with
everything like marriage problems gay
yes guns in school guns in school it
dealt with like um it dealt with so many
different issues insecurities and jared
leto as jordan
he was the [ __ ] hottest pressure to
have sex like he took her to a party i
was like he he was so hot and it's like
i think it also i'm not kidding i think
i dated guys that like couldn't read
because i was like it was another
remember they they dealt with literacy
oh yeah he's gonna he could read and
then i was like i need only idiots i
would only date guys that were like the
stupidest it was just such a great show
i got it i love a good tv show that
moves you i'm so much because i've never
felt more validated because i'm getting
to this like age in life when people are
like what are you talking about yeah
yeah yeah on that note you know what you
feel oh but just real quick you know
when you realize you're getting old you
know sometimes you just things happen
because i had this funny thing with
rachel like like we both felt really old
so i got this gift gift bag and it it's
actually a cooler and a bag you know
what i mean so like when you open it up
like you can keep red bulls and stuff
yeah like a trader joe's literally right
right right i think so i i said rachel
here you can have this so she took
everything out of the bag and she's now
using it as her purse
and she put like a little thing of
grapes in it and she's telling me she's
like oh my god the grapes were still
cold and i was like you're so old now
look that's an old like if you were if
you were like 14 and your mom was like
look at my back you'd be like mom that's
a cooler and she was just like it just
you just realize you the things you
think are cool now yeah like if you
think about like young people are going
to look at you like are you crazy like
that well also it's like oh my god
you're not going to believe how much
sleep i got last night right right this
was incredible i went to bed at 9 00 p.m
last night all the things that uh all
the things that we uh like as you get
older the things you think are like holy
this is the stuff that's when you feel
like you're out it's when you get out of
touch that's what being old is it's just
out of touch with what young people
think is cool yeah or if you're like ice
cream for breakfast and then you're like
that's not if you have ice cream for
breakfast now you're like there's
something you start talking about what
it's gonna do to you i always do a vibe
check with jules i'm like jules what i'm
how am i reading today old young am i
reading gen x gen z millennial am i
reading gender yeah but with her you're
you are you old
with her
you mentioned that she has a mother i
always keep i i don't know why in my
head you're going to like reveal to me
at one point that you had it
i mean look it could have happened that
would be something that would have been
on my so-called life oh yes
why there was and it's really my kid
that would have been a toilet paper
toilet ran when i had a toilet baby oh
ray oh my god imagine an alcoholic you
[Applause]
wait did she really have a toilet baby
no no but she would oh that would have
been she was the bad girl bad influence
i think i think that's another reason i
was a bad girl too i mean these shows
had a lot i also really like watch her
around bobby she might
no i never was that part i never was
that hard i always i never fought over
dick you can have the day i will say
this about annie fighting over the dick
would be about she was
she doesn't read that way at all when i
first met annie like her and i are very
like
we girl code is thick between yes that's
good yeah no i make sure people i'm like
i would never and i am very so i'm so
attracted to bobby and i i just slide
off the chair when i think about him
i just you know our friendship is more
important thank you so much what she
basically just said is thank god bobby
isn't hot at all
no i would never i'm not i really am
good at it's almost like when i i used
to work at actually a restaurant called
the cowgirl and i just have to dress
like this
there was karaoke
on fridays or one of the days so i was
so good at like i can block music out
and i think it's the same i like i can
ver i'm not attracted to people what
happened to her i i will i think we
could all do that also you people it
happened to you you when you were young
you meet with becky right she
she had a best friend who took one of
her boyfriends when she was really young
so that [ __ ] sticks with you yeah yeah
yeah yeah and you just it was so
difficult i don't know what it was
though it was what you were saying it
was like what ryan was doing where it's
like a jealousy of what someone else has
yes it ain't about to it ain't nothing
it had nothing to do with the guy
whether you're attracted or not it's
about like in our friendship i have to
be better than you right you know and
that's what it that's a whole different
vibe
and she was like even if she wasn't
better than her with school and stuff
she was like the sexual yes yes yes yes
i need to have this you know oh my god
no but you know what why don't you guys
start uh my so-called life i know
podcasts
george set it up
we can all do because i know exactly
what you mean because i was thinking
about like cause like the other day when
i came here she walks in with like
lingerie on in a shawl
and very matronly it was very yeah she
ruined it with a grandma from ross she
had a cane you know but for me my first
thought is like what the [ __ ] going on
here like
it wasn't even a thought to me to be
like well damn you know and i think that
a lot of that has to do with like i knew
subconsciously that is part of like my
relationship with bobby and you know my
own thing and i was just like so you can
be like that but can you also see we all
can be like that but can you also see
where when you said that she was giving
sexual hugs that maybe she wasn't giving
sexual hugs and maybe i could promise
you from the bottom of my head his face
is so funny from the bottom of my uterus
no no no no she
you were a different person back then no
no no no no no no no with all due
respect well i like you very much as a
person and never in my life have i ever
perceived you or even wanted to give you
a sexual hug i'm sorry if my b cup
titties got in the way and made it
sexual but that's maybe why it took them
out because maybe dudes like you were
perceiving the wrong way oh it's me it's
my fault okay so now i'm not i can't be
gaslit okay you were almost gonna
you know what i'm talking george
hey it's time for a game guys we're
going to play mustache ride or nah okay
oh yeah great segway
are we going to ride this mustache or
not
[Laughter]
is that what this is george
yes we have famous people with mustaches
uh men mostly and uh
in honor of the cowboy episode
now i have i hope that there's a woman
in here just because you said hey the
cowboy episode episode let's say uh
would you ride their mustache annie
i mean look you could put a whole
[ __ ]
dollop of [ __ ] in his mouth and i'd
still write i'm gonna be so bad at this
game because i don't i'm not attracted
to actors
doesn't he look like
benicio del toro who does a little bit
that's her boy that's my boy don't ever
say brad pitt looks like a benny
jillian bell from workaholics yeah loves
that guy too benicio because he looks so
grimy and he looks like he's a choker
honestly i remember being on stage uh i
was in canada and it was like a few
years a few years back and like bad pit
used to be like the joke you would make
about like if the the hottest guy around
you'd be like oh what are you brad pitt
rap it would be the joke it's shania
song you know so i said to this girl in
the crowd like oh what are you like
something about brad pitt and she was
like ew isn't he like 40
and i was like oh [ __ ] i was thinking
about that who's the new hot guy now
i'm noah centeno do you guys want to
know yeah who is that noah centennials
from um all the boys i've loved before
have you seen that no with laura jean
come on guys
let me see it i know all the hot young
boys because jules keeps me
up to date but that's that
no yes i swear to god that's that's him
no no no a couple other ones but she
doesn't even find you know ryan gosling
was art like ryan gosling that's nice
but even he's now old he's old yeah he's
[ __ ]
that's the one i was going to give you
eric yeah
if ryan gosling's old now too like who
like that's
funny it's when you're out of touch
that's what makes you old i feel out of
touch i don't know who the hot guys are
now i was watching i was watching like
these disney movies with my nieces and
uh you know like the disney channel
movies um
and they have the descendants which is
all like the the the children of the
heroes and villains and disney movies
and i'm like oh this like captain hook
kid's [ __ ] hot as [ __ ] i'm like am i
allowed to be saying this [ __ ] with
like a nine-year-old i'm like oh my god
and i looked him up and he was 25 and i
was like oh my god these young and then
i realized my boyfriend's 27.
you live in the dream
they do that right they should do that
and i realize why they do it now
they don't want aunties uh they don't
want aunties confused about their
feelings yes oh my god it's eric griffin
it's bobby
if we had a baby this is our baby bobby
mustache right or not teach marine all
day all night yes let me write that
music but does he that just looks right
on him mm-hmm it didn't look right on
brad pitt brad pitt was like obviously
playing a role this is like i know i
know that's what i'm saying this is like
his yeah okay he would feel we would all
feel like our dad when our dad shaved
his mustache you know did you ever have
that where you're like who are you i
know but doesn't he still look amazingly
young and the mustache doesn't age him
like it does yeah he's hot he doesn't
look like a papaya in this yeah but also
chicha's at that sort of um
that vagina level too i think he's a
short guy so you wouldn't have to do
much wow i didn't realize how hot he was
but um nope um yeah it's not a challenge
it looks like my mustache like legit
yeah and when the eyebrows are bigger
than the mustache nope although i do
like canteen floss do you know what
those are that style
what's that it's with the it's kind of
thinner
i forgot our awesome
the you know
the guy he was never my guy you know
what i mean honestly i do i do like the
idea of you know what was fun watching
him
knowing that he married jenna dewin and
then watching step up afterwards and
then it was like a it was like a
documentary and watching them bang for
the first time that was pretty by the
way dancers have you guys seen sex life
on netflix i haven't yet is it good but
i hear all about it so much [ __ ] on
that show but just quick behind the
scenes
she actually left her real husband and
kids
for that action i will be watching it i
will be watching they actually got
together in real life so that so when
you watch the show you're going to be
like well i get it the what they're
doing anyway
very brandy so this is her husband on
the right on the show okay yeah and then
he's a great guy it's good looking they
got a kid and you know and then this is
her ex-boyfriend who's the bad boy who
she can't stop [ __ ] yeah she can't
shake what what it was
and
anyways in real life they're banging and
in real life they got together oh
[ __ ]
and he left his chick i don't know i
don't know but what they're doing on
this show yeah is like
now when you and your girl watch the
show or do you [ __ ]
we didn't watch we can't watch shows
together because she doesn't have any
patience
she'll be on episode four and i'm still
in episodes there are many we have like
a big fight so we just we have our own
livestream if there's any like romance
stuff that i watch or any shows that i
watch in a romance movie i never i can
never watch it with anyone even my bobby
not with because you get like
embarrassed no because it's like i want
to feel it for myself i know exactly
what you're saying i don't it's like and
then i don't want the guilt of feeling
like should i be thinking about you
whatever it's like can i just have it's
a fantasy yeah you don't want your girl
looking at you like well what are you
liking that
not have to watch it a certain way am i
no matter what i'm by the way no matter
what i'm watching like you're watching
my so-called live well i was just gonna
say i had to watch it alone i couldn't
watch it with my parents because you
pick who you want to be in this but i
was like i was watching like oh my god i
was like riding my heel not knowing what
i was doing i can you watch you guys
have to watch this show and it's an
irish show it's called um normal people
and
i i watched it twice through it came out
right during the beginning of the
pandemic and i
cannot imagine watching that and
enjoying it with bobby it is so
emotional and so romantic and so sexual
that i'm like there's just no way he
would have took me out of it yeah
sometimes you want to cry yeah and i
cried so much during the show sometimes
you want to cry sometimes you want to
fantasize sometimes you want to just you
just want to have that moment
to yourself well how about that's why
even when you're in a movie theater it's
dark and you're just sitting like this
i'm not sitting like this like
i'm not going like
the movie's over here and you just want
to be like this you don't want to judge
me the only time it's fun to watch
anything with anyone is um with scary
things i you know always think about
this too i was thinking
i've been trying to do a joke about this
i've not made it funny yet but
i do you think like the fear of death is
actually just fomo
like are people actually are you afraid
of like the feeling of death or are you
afraid of just missing out on things
because i think my phone was so strong
that i [ __ ] will eat any [ __ ]
thing you put in front of me that is a
good point because i am so deathly
afraid of heights but when i went
canyoneering and i had to jump like 20
30 feet oh [ __ ] i did it because i of
that same fomo where my fomo is so
strong it's stronger than any
imminent
danger i feel
like and fear of heights that i have
altogether i don't understand it but i i
know what you mean like because i'm not
afraid of the experience of dying
because that feels to me like eating a
bug too where i'm like oh i want to know
what that feels like do you know what i
mean i'm not afraid of the actual act of
it once unless you know but
that's because you're thinking of it
maybe in a you know such a fun way or
nice way but it's like do you want to be
eaten by shark
but i think
do you want to be like like slowly put
into acid first
i think because of all the hallucinogens
that i i think no matter how you die i
think it is it is a beautiful experience
where you fizz off like that's how i
feel so like even if there's the pain
there and your body helps you [ __ ]
deal with pain yes your body throws it
in fact most of the time like especially
if it's like a slower death like when
you're in the hospital setting like my
mom was a hospice nurse for a decade so
she saw people on their way out often um
your body protects you from that
experience and it goes into a coma like
the only time really that you're like
aware is if you have trouble breathing
this and that but eventually you will
slip into a coma to prevent you from
knowing that experience i'm
claustrophobic so
i anytime i watch a movie and it's like
people are like buried alive yeah oh
buried alive is the worst way to die for
me [ __ ] with
when i think about like visiting egypt
i'm like oh i would never know like what
the pyramids would feel like on the
inside because i wouldn't dare take i
tell myself like i'm so claustrophobic i
would never do that but then i was just
in hawaii recently and
knowing how claustrophobic i am there
are these tunnels like you dive down 30
feet and then you go through these rock
tunnels underneath where if you look up
you're just in this tight little cave
and you have the swim swim swim swim
swim and eventually it's you know you
swim your way back out right but you're
completely encased my fomo was so
[ __ ] bad yeah that my heart was
[ __ ] jumping out of my chest but i
had to do it you don't want to miss out
on that experience or whatever there's
always something like i think you
learned this with comedy too it's like
the worst thing that happens you can
always get a joke out of it like there's
always like a silver lining a bad thing
not a live stream
to tell it which is why i find myself
only able to
uh really connect with
or not that i only can connect with i
prefer to connect with a comedian
or
or people directly around comedians
because there is something that is
there's like this understanding
you know no matter what the situation is
it's not that we're trying to make light
of things right it's just it's about
it's about it analyzing of the situation
to find out all the different things
about it
uh to appreciate it and that the most
important thing is laughter it's not
about offend not offending each other
it's like like our agreement is that our
top
priority priority is laughter he's like
joking saying the funniest thing so it's
like even to take it even deeper not
even just laughter as much as like
understanding that laughter is us
acknowledging that we feel the same way
about this
or i'm saying to you i know where you're
coming from and i said i do that by
going like this
[Laughter]
you know what i mean but that's
but that's what but
but that's what we're doing i think when
we're like because i always tell people
it's like you know you know when you're
to get people to laugh is a response
that they get from
it's a visceral response to any emotion
yeah whether you're sad angry you could
be angry at somebody and you laugh right
you could be you know you're upset or
you're crying at a funeral you could
laugh i mean anywhere it's because that
is that base emotion a base response and
i think we're all about that and it's
and it it's
sets off endorphins it's happiness so
it's like you know what it shows us that
no matter [ __ ] what you can always
like nothing is too dark
i gotta say that there isn't a hotter
sheriff in town
thank you oh you're a sheriff what oh i
didn't see you know what a bounty hunter
i just saw that
i'm sure guns didn't make sense before
that no sheriff muffin top the bounty
hunter
i thought she could have been a train
robber or like a like you know she's all
in black so you know back in the day it
was the bad guy the bad was the bad guy
so thank you guys so much for yet
another episode thank you eric griffin
do you have anything on a plug actually
i'm going to be at the brea improv one
night on the 19th
oh and i'm gonna be at the trembler uh
brewing company but it's sold out so you
can cut that part out ooh don't don't
that that's great and he is a seller
outer these days sell her out or come to
my shows guys before they sell out even
if it doesn't sell out it's very fun we
have such a good time
we'll see you guys next week thank you
so much eric
[Music]
you